this american carnage stops
right here and stops
right now
the rise of donald j trump from
television star to become the most
powerful man in the world was a story
that not even the most creative reality
show producer
could ever have imagined but the
disruptive candidate tapped into a vein
of discontent
and in 2016 secured the biggest
property deal of his life winning the
keys to 1600 pennsylvania avenue
it was to be the start of a dramatic
four years
for america and for the world
he made his name as a new york property
developer but it was the apprentice
that gave donald trump the platform and
audience he needed to run for office
and in 2015 he threw his hat into the
ring
i am officially running
for president of the united states
and we are going to make our country
great again
donald trump was controversial from the
off no one gave him a chance but he
galvanized support against his more
popular opponent
hillary clinton it's just awfully good
that someone
with the temperament of donald trump is
not in charge of the law
in our country because you'd be in jail
secretary clinton
[Applause]
he vowed to make america great again and
didn't care
how he achieved it his campaign promised
to build a wall on the border with
mexico to keep immigrants out
was dismissed as immoral and inhumane
going to pay for the wall but his base
in the red republican states
loved it trump's tactics might have been
crass
but they worked in november 2016 he
squeezed home
defeating clinton and leaving the world
open mail
and confirmed that donald trump will be
the 45th
president of the united states
on january 20th 2017 donald trump
swore the oath and took office the 45th
president
of the united states of america i donald
john trump
do solemnly swear that i will faithfully
execute that i will faithfully execute
the office of president of the united
states
the office of president of the united
states
so help me god so help me god
congratulations mr president
trump would thrive on running battles
between his version of the truth
and the establishment's record of events
look at all that news back there look at
all that fake news
he coined the term fake news and
weaponized it
to his advantage
i'm not going to give you a question you
are fake news
you knew that the president was awake
just by looking at twitter
he seemed to start his days online
fueled by the morning news
and berating anyone who got in his way
the fbi investigated accusations of
russian interference in the 2016
election
and his summits with president putin
only fueled his opponent's anger
and then with the revelations that he
tried to coerce ukraine
into helping him score points against
his rival joe biden the democratic party
here on capitol hill
saw it as their opportunity to remove
him from office
but it failed trump's four years were
punctuated by a series of
tell-all book releases everyone from
journalists
former aides and even family members
tried to smear the commander-in-chief
by putting their accounts into print for
much of the time
it was like water off a duck's back the
turnover of white house staff
was phenomenal anyone who broke from the
mould
was out by the time november's election
there were fewer than 10 of the original
staff remaining
and two of those were his daughter and
son-in-law
the style is a catastrophe the style has
uplifted extremist rhetoric allied the
office of the presidency
with some of the lowest and most extreme
elements in our society
it's um it's gone from having a critique
of corruption to appearing to make just
about every aspect of the law in america
as for sale
to the highest bidder president trump
split the nation
and divided the world my administration
has accomplished more than
almost any administration in the history
of our country
america's so true
didn't expect that reaction but that's
okay
in just four years he reshaped the
international norms
pulling america out of key agreements
including the paris climate accord
the iranian nuclear deal and the un
human rights council
from day one he set his sights on nato
the bedrock
of transatlantic defense for over seven
decades
countries that aren't fulfilling their
commitment in those countries are going
to be dealt with
maybe i'll deal with them from a trade
standpoint maybe i'll deal with them in
a different way
i'll work something out where they have
to pay but you know we don't want to
have people delinquent
trump's unconventional style of
diplomacy was brash
and unpredictable long-term allies
suddenly found themselves on the end of
public outbursts
he told his supporters he would end wars
in the middle east and bring american
troops home
he failed sometimes tell his allies
though
it's the biggest material in the history
we will never forget that when he
declared victory over islamic state
and pulled u.s forces out of syria in
2019
it left the kurds exposed and furious
and he shut the palestinians out to
strike a deal with israel
trumpeted as peace but far from perfect
the normalization of relations between
israel and the gulf states was a small
coup
no doubt but the palestinians anger
hasn't gone away
and neither had the middle east's
problems you have seen a decrease of
military engagements of the us around
the world
i mean it's the first presidency in a
very long time where you didn't see the
active military being moved in
to to be some type of peacekeeping force
you know you saw the president commit to
his word
of of trying to bring home the troops
from afghanistan
of trying to bring home the the troops
from iraq
he brought the art of the deal from the
boardroom to the oval office
and there was a pattern first threatened
rocket man is on a suicide mission for
himself
and for his regime
[Music]
then flatter and it's my honor and
we will have a terrific relationship i
have no doubt
occasionally it worked more often it
didn't
china grew stronger and became public
enemy number one
the transactional commander-in-chief
aimed his sights on beijing
first over trade and more recently
over covered what he has done with
china for better or for worse is to turn
it
in the view of the world and certainly
the view of the united states
from being a partner
to being an adversary if you look at it
as a needle on a dial
the needle is flicked from partnership
to the state
of adversaries and that will result in
profound changes in foreign policy not
only in the united states
but also with the president biden but
also
in european and others
there was one head of state though who
trump was
truly in oral his state visit the uk in
2019
had him visibly moved queen elizabeth
managed
what no other world figure seemingly
could the donald
was humbled so
i then go up and meet the queen
and she is fantastic we then go up and
we have tea
and i didn't know this it was supposed
to last for 15 minutes but it lasted for
like an hour because we got along
we got along with trademark exaggeration
trump claimed he built america's
greatest ever
economy that wasn't quite true although
at the start of 2020
unemployment was the lowest it had been
in 50 years wages were growing
and the poverty rate was at an all-time
low
the kobe pandemic destroyed all that
trump initially dismissed it waved it
off and then i see the disinfectant
where it knocks it out in a minute one
minute
and is there a way we can do something
like that
by injection inside or
but the pandemic had no respect for the
superpower it's going to disappear one
day it's like a miracle it will
disappear
and from our shores we've you know it
could get worse before it gets better
could maybe go away we'll see what
happens nobody really knows
president trump is about to be taken to
walter reed army medical center
but for all the bold bluster trump also
came down with covert
the president was flown to hospital for
treatment
much of america is still in a sort of
lockdown
shops are boarded up businesses are
closed and hundreds of thousands of
people
have lost their lives to covid and yet
donald trump
at times mocked the disease for a long
period he refused to wear a mask
he publicly argued and disagreed with
his medical experts
and close to the election he started
holding big outdoor rallies
where hundreds of his supporters were
crammed in cheek by jowl
but it would have been wrong to write
him off he beat the odds once
and he might have done so again when
riots broke out following the killing
of george floyd by a police officer
trump sought to be the president of law
and order
he put the military on the streets of
u.s cities creating further racial and
societal tension
but knowing that it would go down well
with his core base just months away from
the election
trump quietly filled the federal courts
with conservative judges
and the death of ruth bader ginsburg
gave him an opportunity
to appoint a third justice to the
supreme court
another shot in the arm to galvanize the
republican right
amy coney barrett was sworn in just days
before the election
she could end up being trump's most
impactful legacy
but his actions in the dying weeks of
his presidency
will define his time in office
he refused to go quietly using his
lawyers to spread
false claims of election fraud you can't
ever accept when they steal and rig
and rob
[Applause]
and he whipped up his supporters
encouraging them
to overturn democracy it was finally
a step too far he was criticized
by his own party and world leaders
and donald trump became the first
president in history
to be impeached twice
donald trump was idolized by his
supporters
loathed by his enemies and mocked by
much of the media
he leaves behind a nation still in the
grip of a pandemic
made worse by his failure to take it
seriously
his presidential legacy will be a united
states of america
divided and adrift alastair uncle sky
news
washington